and just like that we're at the End of
the World Cup
here are our top five Trends from Qatar
we saw some big upsets day three of the
tournament produced a huge shot Saudi
Arabia beating one of the favorites
Argentina other early upsets saw Spain
and France beaten excuse me
while Germany and Belgium didn't even
make it past the group stage and perhaps
the biggest surprise of all was Morocco
who's rocked to the semi-finals was a
source of joy and pride for Africans and
Arabs alike
one of the tournament's big Winners
wasn't even playing
people from a host of different nations
United around the Palestinian cause its
flag was shown everywhere when Morocco
unfurled it after one of its themes it
gave us one of the tournament's most
striking images
there were protests too before Germany's
first World Cup match which they lost to
Japan the players posed for their team
photo with their hands over their mouths
the gestures seemed to be a protest
against FIFA's ban of the one love
armband several teams were planning to
wear them in support of lgbtq plus
rights but decided against it after
threats from FIFA in the end Germany
failed to advance past the group speech
but Germany weren't the only ones
protesting before their Opening match
Iranian players refused to see their
national anthem their silence was seen
as a show of solidarity with the rights
protests that had swept across Iran
there were even moments for fans to
experience new cultures
this moment went viral a Qatari police
officer helping an Ecuador fan with his
flip it up a traditional headdress born
in Qatar as the tournament went on more
and more visitors tried on local attire
soon enough stadiums and fan zones were
full of colorful thugs like these
we also had World Cup slogans
[Music]
after a historic win against Portugal
Morocco fans chose Superstar Cristiano
Ronaldo the World Cup exit
three days earlier they had done the
same after defeating Spain
so where did that slogan come from it
all started with this guy
23 year olds known as qatar's Metro man
he went viral on social media for
showing fans how to get home after the
matches his catchy slogan caught on
quickly
[Music]
[Applause]